the Justice Department is suing to block
18 T's 85 billion dollar purchase of
Time Warner the owner of CNN you are
fake news president Trump's frequent
criticism of CNN is raising concerns
about the motive behind the government's
legal challenge Julianna Goldman is at
the Justice Department Juliana good
morning good morning the Justice
Department says the merger would harm
competition increased prices for
consumers and result in less innovation
DOJ also says that the newly combined
firm would be able to charge rivaled
cable distributors hundreds of millions
of dollars more per year for Time
Warner's programming those costs would
be passed down to the consumer but AT&T
has argued the merger would allow them
to deliver cheaper programming over the
Internet
rather than an expensive cable bundle
packages and they also seal that say
that this deal is considered what's
called a vertical merger meaning it's
between two companies in the same
industry who don't directly compete now
during the 2016 presidential campaign
then candidate Donald Trump said that he
would oppose the deal because it would
concentrate too much power in the hands
of too few but at a press conference
yesterday on Monday AT&T CEO Randall
Stephenson said he didn't know if the
lawsuit was all about CNN but Gail he
did say that selling the network was a
non-starter all right thank you very
much Julianna